group think when it comes to ethnicity
uh when it comes to gender why do you
think that that's one of the primal sins
in your view of quote political
correctness well i think it's one of the
primal sins of identity politics players
on the left and the right just to be
clear about that
personally since this has got personal
at times i'm no fan of the identitarian
right i think that anybody who plays a
game a conceptual game where group
identity comes first and foremost risks
an exacerbation of tribalism it doesn't
matter whether it's on the left or the
right
with regards to the idea of group rights
well there's a fundamental and this is
something we fall into terribly in
canada not least because we had to
contend with the threat of quebec
separatism but the the idea of group
rights is extraordinarily problematic
because
the
the the obverse of the coin of
individual rights is individual
responsibilities and you can hold an
individual responsible and an individual
can be responsible
and so that's partly why individuals
have rights
but groups
how do you hold a group responsible
i mean the whole idea is not it's not a
good idea to hold a group responsible
first of all it flies in the face of the
idea of the sort of justice systems that
we've laid out in the west that are
essentially predicated first on the
assumptions you know what
do you know what that is to me right
and i'm just gonna say it i
think there are certain groups of people
that
if someone individual does something a
whole group gets categorized about it
yeah do you know what i mean so we say
if a black person does something if a
mexican person does something or if our
person does something right the group
get look gets looked at like
oh like those people are crazy however i
think and a lot of white people i think
don't have this
they don't know that a white person can
do something individually and they don't
get seen the same way
by the other groups so like white people
so like black people
mexicans arabs
don't necessarily tend to look up all
white people a certain way if a white
person does something really what do you
think i think that's wrong all right
because i always hear like white people
that's what they always say like oh
white people or oh like
you're so white i hear that all the time
and i also hear when there's a mass
shooting that's always their first
response says oh was the shooter white
so the thing is i think
i think it also has to do with i'm not
saying you're wrong right yeah i'm
saying i think it also has to do with
influence and power okay
because
i think
certain groups of people have more
influence and power so for instance
black people don't run media stations
generally so they can't
show a constant barrage
of like crazy white people look
they're crazy
do you know what i mean however like
media stations
can do that and a lot of the times do
portray a certain image of black people
anal mexicans and other arabs
i don't know i
i feel like the media has always talked
about white people too
i'm like because i always hear in the
media like like i feel like that's the
group that i always hear about it's like
because like the phrase is like oh white
people oh the white like
the one percent the white men
i mean
i hear that yeah
i just think
but i just don't really look at people
in that way like i just feel like it's
kind of silly to group people by
race when there's so many different but
the thing is that's what this is the
thing obviously that's what see i'm a
black male right so my experience you're
a white woman right you will have
different experiences within the world
right so
my experience knowing who i am mm-hmm i
know i'm not a criminal you know i've
been in prison i've been to jail
never sold drugs
but i know that
there is a perception
of black males okay you know what i mean
by the general society it's not just
white people okay because we get we get
we internalize it too okay sometimes
we're in the black community do you know
what i'm saying so we feel like
a black guy's gotta know how to play
basketball or he's gotta know how to
dance so he's gotta know how to do
something it's like we don't all do that
yeah
well i mean the other stereotypes you
know what i mean like it's a stereotype
yeah so
i think yeah i just think i think we
should continue i think yeah well i
wanna hear i wanna hear some more
question of individual innocence but
also on the possibility of individual
guilt not group guilt
we saw what happened in the 20th century
many many times when the idea of group
guilt was it was it it was enabled to
get a foothold let's say in the polity
and in the justice system it was
absolutely catastrophic and so okay fine
group rights well what are you going to
how are you going to contend with the
alternative to that the opposite of that
that where's the group responsibility
how are you going to keep how are you
going to hold your groups responsible
well we don't have to talk about that
because we're too concerned with
rectifying hypothetical
rectifying historical injustices
hypothetical and otherwise and that's
certainly not to say that there weren't
any shortage of absolutely catastrophic
historical injustices that's not the
point the point is
how you so pearl do you think right what
you just said there do you think that
historical catastrophes must be
compensated for no no that's stupid
so then
i'm not saying i'm not agreeing or
disagree yeah so then
how come
there were groups of people that got
compensation then
okay for instance like jewish people
chinese japanese people with the with
the with the bombs like there were
groups of people who got compensated i
don't know
so it wasn't fair
what well i'm talking about like when i
when i think about group i think about
reparations
so i don't
i mean maybe if if the people were still
alive today like i don't know maybe
but
like when you said historical i thought
you meant like at the past
present yeah so like in the past that's
like people talk about slavery so in the
past you know the holocaust happened in
the past you know yeah japanese but
people got compensated for it yeah do
you know what i mean and this thing
actually one of the things i think i
think it's a doubleheaded sword with a
lot of black people actually because you
can double edge between victimhood and
not and it's like
it's like give us our money it's like
first of all i don't think reparations
is viable
first of all um i don't think any
country is going to [ __ ] their
economy for a bunch of people
i just don't believe that it's going to
happen
um however do i think
given the um
[Music]
there's a book right called how the how
europe underdeveloped africa
and when you read that book you realize
that the whole industrial revolution and
stuff like that was started because of
the colonization and you just think
well if you didn't if you didn't do that
then you wouldn't be as successful
so what do you mean by the colonization
so the colonization of africa so
both the people
and the resources right
there's a direct correlation between the
colonization of africa and the
industrial revolution okay and so with
all the metals and the rubber and all
this kind of stuff coming from africa
okay it fueled the industrial revolution
of the west
wait so
you're saying like in africa when you
say colonized you're saying like like
did england come in and call it yeah
like so european france spain portugal
england and they like enslaved africans
and then yes that's what you're saying
okay so they well they they enslaved at
least colonize the
the continent okay so
when you colonize a continent and then
you take
then you take ownership of the resources
you're able to gather those resources
together and use them to your own
benefits right and so you gather those
resources using your own benefit and
build up your economy right all the
while
messing up the economy of that actual
country and so it's like
well would the west have been
as successful